Hey Wisecrack, Jared again.
This is me at the midnight screening of The
Dark Knight Rises back in 2012.
Needless to say, I was out-of-my-mind excited.
But despite my Dark Knight infatuation, I couldn't
help but be disappointed.
(screams)
The Dark Knight Rises is not necessarily a bad movie -
Lock up later.
- it just pales in comparison to its predecessor.
But as with anything graced with the name
Nolan (and by that I mean this one),
this film has a LOT of intellectual ambition.
Unfortunately not all of it pans out.
So let's dive in to see what works... and
what doesn't.
Welcome to this Special Wisecrack Edition
on The Dark Knight Rises: What Went Wrong?
And of course- Spoilers ahead.
A lot of my disappointment with The Dark Knight Rises stems from its smart setup, but questionable execution.
So let's start with one of its smartest elements-
the very unexpected influence of Charles Dickens'
A Tale of Two Cities.
The Dark Knight Rises replicates most of the book's major themes including social inequality,
resurrection, and doubling.
The most obvious thematic parallel with A Tail Of Two Cities is social inequality.
The book's setting, the French Revolution, depicts a decadent aristocracy and their abuse of the poor.
Likewise, the film portrays a similar class conflict through Bane's false revolution.
Now we come here not as conquerors, but as liberators to return control of this city to the people.
The third book in the novel is called "track
of a storm" and Catwoman says:
There's a storm coming, Mr Wayne.
Then there’s the theme of resurrection.
In a Tale of Two Cities, Dickens frequently
uses the phrase “recalled to life” to
signify that his characters are metaphorically
brought back from the dead.
One of the main characters is metaphorically
brought back to life when he sees his daughter
after 18 years in the Bastille (or in his
words "buried alive").
Similarly Bruce Wayne is metaphorically "recalled
to life" when Catwoman steals his fingerprints,
forcing him to leave Wayne Manor after 8 years
of self-imposed isolation.
I care for no man on Earth and no man cares for me.
Another character named Carton is "resurrected"
when he sacrifices himself for another character -
Take my coat. Hurry!
- thus giving meaning to his aimless life.
This arc is reflected in Catwoman -
I'll open that tunnel - then I'm gone.
There's more to you then that.
- who overcomes
her selfishness and saves Batman.
This can also be likened to Officer Foley,
who sacrifices his life to save Gotham after
being complacent with the takeover.
These guys run the city. We've all gotta keep our heads down till they can fix this.
Carton even quotes the story of Lazarus.
Lazarus, of course, being the guy Christ RESURRECTED
in the bible.
Bruce is metaphorically resurrected when he
rebuilds his strength and climbs out of the
LAZARUS pit.
Darnay, the guy Carton saved, is given a second
chance at life when he is spared from execution;
and Bruce is again metaphorically resurrected
when we find out at the end that he is, in
fact, not dead, and is given a second chance
to live a more rewarding life.
Even the title, "The Dark Knight Rises" invokes
a "Phoenix rising from the ashes". The poster
for the film swaps out a phoenix for the bat symbol.
And Chapter 23 from A Tale Of Two Cities
is called "Fire Rises".
Have we started the fire?
Yes, the fire rises.
Oh yeah, and both texts feature a capitalist
named "Stryver".
Make no mistake, Mr. Stryver.
At Batman’s funeral, Gordon even reads this
line about Carton’s sacrifice and moral
resurrection straight from the end of
A Tale Of Two Cities.
It is a far far better thing that I do.
That I have every done.
Finally, there's the theme of doubling.
You've probably heard the opening lines "it
was the best of times, it was the worst of
times" - this contrasting between pairs - between
best and worst of times, between age of wisdom
and foolishness, between the epoch of belief and incredulity - happens throughout the whole book.
There are two Mannettes, two cities- London
and Paris, Darnay has two trials, and Darnay
and Carton look the same.
In the Dark Knight Rises, there's: Two cities
- Gotham and Bane's underground.
Batman and Bane, two League of Shadows alums
who deal with unbearable pain.
Left him in perpetual agony. The mask holds the pain at bay.
One born in privilege, another born in hell.
Blake and Batman are two orphans with anger issues.
Not a lot of people know what it feels like, do they?
To be angry - in your bones.
And a constant reminder of the division between
the body and the soul.
The torture.
Yes, but not of your body - your soul.
So what we’ve got here is probably the most graceful
thematic adaptation from a classic to a comic
book movie in existence.
But the problem is that on top of developing
new themes borrowed from A Tale of Two Cities,
the film also has to juggle the themes established
in The Dark Knight.
And here’s where the film starts to stumble.
One of the essential themes of The Dark Knight
is “Truth versus lies.”
The Dark Knight ends with a noble lie:
I killed those people.
Batman takes responsibility for Harvey Dent’s murders,
thus denying the fall of Gotham’s savior and upholding the image of him as an Ideal symbol
of justice and hope.
A thug who showed his true nature when he betrayed the trust of this great man.
Herein lies one of the most squandered opportunities
of the film.
I believed in Harvey Dent.
Many incredible works end with a noble lie.
In Joseph Conrad’s Heart of Darkness, for
example, Marlowe lies to Kurz’s intended
by telling her that that Kurtz's last words
were her name, saving her from the truth that
he died a deranged psychopath.
Or in Alan Moore’s Watchmen the team agrees
to preserve Ozymandias’s lie that millions
were killed by an extraterrestrial force in
order to maintain peace between the US and the USSR.
However, both Heart of Darkness and Watchmen
end without the truth ever coming out.
We’re left to ponder: What is more important?
The truth?
Or the saving lie?
The Dark Knight leaves us with the same ambiguity,
but the Dark Knight Rises picks up where these
stories left off (thematically, of course):
So finally we get to see what happens when
a noble lie is exposed to the vulgar truth.
Maybe it's time we all stop trying to all outsmart the truth and let it have its day.
Does the film live up to the challenge?
Unfortunately, Not really.
At the beginning of The Dark Knight Rises, we see that the noble lie has manifested itself in The Dent Act,
a piece of legislation that allows cops
increasing power to persecute organized crime.
No city is without crime, but this city is without organized crime because the Dent Act
gave law enforcement teeth in its fight against the mob.
There are two ways this can be read: We can
read it as a metaphor for the Patriot Act,
a law criticized for giving the government
a dangerous amount of power to fight terrorism.
Considering many interpret the Joker’s radicalism as a reflection of Al Qaeda extremism, this makes sense.
Or 2, Harvey Dent can be read as a Christ figure WITHOUT resurrection - a kind of atheistic interpretation.
Imagine if Christ never came back to life,
but people fabricated the lie that he DID
in order to maintain his divine status and
create a religious institution founded on a lie.
Based on this reading, Christ, like Dent would
be a false idol, but one that must be upheld
in order to maintain peace and hope.
So I could, to my shame, build a lie around this fallen idol
Gothamites even celebrate his legacy with
“Harvey Dent Day,” which I’m sure will
be moved to late December to stimulate the economy.
Harvey Dent Day may not be our oldest, public holiday,
but we're here tonight because
it's one of the most important.
Considered in this light, the Dent Act can
be likened to the way that religion has been
used to justify overreaching acts of power
like the Inquisition.
As juicy as this sounds, neither of these
extended metaphors actually pan out, because
contrary to what the film wants us to assume,
there is no evidence that the product of the
lie is corrupt.
In fact, the Dent Act seems to work wonders.
When you and Dent cleaned up the streets you cleaned them good.
Pretty soon we'll be chasing down...uh...over due
library books.
Once Bane reveals the truth that Harvey Dent
is a false idol and the Dent Act is built
off this lie, it leads to social unrest.
So is the film trying to say that bad stuff
happens when the truth is revealed?
It seems so, considering when Alfred reveals
the truth about Rachel choosing Dent over Bruce -
What if before she died she wrote a letter saying she choice Harvey Dent over you?
- It just drives them further apart and encourages
Bruce to go on his suicide mission.
But the problem comes when the film doubles
back to the conclusion at the end of the Dark
Knight: because everything is only fixed when
the truth is buried and another lie is established.
At the end Wayne lies about the Bat’s autopilot
being broken so that he could fake his death.
Thus the narrative of Batman sacrificing himself
for Gotham creates another image of justice
for Gotham to revere.
The final lines from A Tale Of Two Cities that Gordon quotes during Bruce’s funeral reflect Carton’s
christ-like sacrifice, thereby suggesting
Batman’s sacrifice is also Christ like.
However, as the final shots of the movie proves,
Batman did NOT sacrifice himself for Gotham,
but perhaps it’s necessary to believe the
lie that he did, just as it was necessary
to believe the lie that Harvey Dent
was noble until the end.
After spending nearly 3-fucking-hours to find
out how this theme of truth will develop,
we end up exactly at the same spot as the
end of the Dark Knight; establishing the necessity
of a lie to uphold faith in justice.
Ugh.
If the theme of the noble lie were to truly
develop, we might be presented with a scenario
in which the toxic lies lead to so much corruption
that revealing the lie is more beneficial
than letting it fester and destroy Gotham.
The film attempts this by suggesting that
the corruption of the Dent Act leads to Bane’s
social revolution, as evidenced by Gordon’s quote:
Bane is SUPPOSED to be the outcome of this toxic lie.
Given Gordon’s words, it seems like Bane
was meant to function, like the Joker did,
as a product of escalation.
In the Dark Knight we got SUPER clear exposition
that SHOWS the state of society that leads
to the rise of the Joker.
Nah man. I don't like tonight.
What are you superstitious? You got more chance at winning the powerball than runnin' into him.
Batman has put so many drug dealers out of
business, and inspired so much fear -
If you don't like what I have to offer, you can buy from someone else.
Assuming Batman left anyone to buy from.
- that the mob has been pushed to desperation, leading
to the rise of a radically antithetical form
of Batman’s brand of justice- The Joker.
I thought my jokes were bad.
It seems Gordon was trying to suggest that
that when abusive power based on a lie leads
to unsavory political and economic tensions,
a violent reaction is bound to happen.
But once again, we have no evidence of this
corruption at the hands of the Dent Act, or
the lie that justifies it.
In one scene, Catwoman tricks a man threatening
her life by making him use the cellphone of
a missing congressman, and SECONDS later,
the police bombard in.
This could be read as an indication that the Dent Act allows for the monitoring of everyone's cell phones
which would make sense given the Patriot Act parallel.
but problem is- this saves Catwoman’s life!
Without this kind of power, Catwoman would be dead.
Why not show us the negative consequences
of invasive surveillance?
The film throws away this opportunity to comment
on how those in power can use a lie to justify
excessive authority.
This brings us to to the second theme of the movie- pain.
- (Alfred) Did you really pay for it?
- (Batman) Well you're very welcome to try it, Alfred.
This, theme, like truth, spends nearly three
hours developing just to bring us back to
where we started.
At the beginning, Bruce, stricken with physical
pain and the pain of losing Rachel, doesn’t
leave his mansion.
He overcomes his pain when he heals his back
and escapes the Lazarus pit.
But he ultimately gives into pain again when
decides to stop being Batman, fucks off to
Italy, and starts livin’ that bored billionaire lifestyle.
Now I’m going to bring another literary
work in here to possibly defend the cyclical
nature of these two themes-
George Orwell’s Animal Farm.
See, in Animal Farm, Orwell does a very clever
thing: the term “revolution” is given
a double meaning.
On the one hand, it denotes the revolution
when the animals overthrow their human oppressors.
But the original definition of “revolution”
is also given significance because the novel
comes FULL CIRCLE -- it revolves.
At the end, The pigs are just like the humans
they overthrew, greedy capitalists.
So could the Nolans be playing with this double
meaning of the word revolution by having the
themes of pain and truth come full circle
in a film about a social revolution?
Maybe, or maybe I’m just giving them too much
credit, you guys decide.
The third major theme of the film is social inequality.
But whereas a Tale of Two Cities aptly displays
the decadence and corruption of the elite
that leads to social unrest, The Dark Knight
Rises gives us a vague, muddy and almost nonsensical
display of the social tensions that lead to
Bane’s false revolution against the rich.
According to Bane, Blackgate Prison is a symbol
of the Dent Act’s oppression.
Behind you stands a symbol of repression.
Blackgate is overcrowded, men and women sometimes
share cell blocks, and criminals under the
Dent Act don’t get parole.
Sure, it’s harsh and unjust, but it’s
hardly the gratuitous cruelty we see in, say,
A Tale of Two Cities.
Fear and slavery keep the scum obedient.
These unfortunate realities seem to pale in comparison to the overwhelming success of the Dent Act.
There are 1,000 inmates in Blackgate prison as a direct result of the Dent Act.
These are violent criminals, essential cogs in the organized crime machine.
Especially considering that the law’s inability
to fight crime is a central conflict in the
first two films.
And even if Blackgate was wrongfully imprisoning people, how does that translate to overthrowing the rich?
Blackgate is a clear stand-in for the Bastille
during the French Revolution, and drawing
that analogy out farther, the Dent Act is
meant to be the French “Lettres de Cachet”
a kind of “warrant” issued by the king
of France that detained people without being
burdened by annoying shit like
“proof” or “reasonable suspicion."
The Bastille became a symbol for the excesses
of the King’s authority: people could be
thrown in jail for practicing the wrong religion,
or criticizing the government, or pissing off
the wrong nobleman at the wrong time.
And when popular rage finally reached a breaking
point: the Bastille was an obvious target.
Problem is, this analogy doesn’t really fit because
Blackgate does none of these things.
King Louis didn’t go around eradicating
the mob and making France safe with his authority.
And if the Gotham police are abusing their
authority, like Louis, we’re not shown it.
I also suppose that would have complicated the final showdown scene in which the cops are the good guys.
So if The Dent Act alone doesn’t justify
people overthrowing Gotham’s social structures,
maybe it’s something else?
The kid in the orphanage suggests that the
economic situation is making orphans go in
to the sewers and join Bane’s army -
- but we’re
given zero indication on how the Dent Act
or Blackgate are disenfranchising the poor.
The only evidence we see of elite corruption
is when Daggit tries to steal Wayne Enterprises
from Bruce Wayne, but that’s the rich screwing over the rich, not the rich screwing over the poor.
Some people have condemned The Dark Knight
Rises as anti-Occupy Wall Street propaganda
for this very reason.
I said - I said no rye.
It shows a society that seeks vengeance on
the rich for no other reason than they’re
rich, and sets up kangaroo courts to punish them.
No lawyer. No witnesses.
What sort of due process is this?
Without actually establishing what these people
are rebelling against, it makes it look like
the film is painting Occupy activists as nothing
more than easily manipulated fascistic clowns.
It’s more an issue of underdeveloped worldbuilding,
and not necesarilly politically-charged moralizing.
As I said earlier, The Dark Knight Rises
is far from a bad film.
It unfortunately falls short, but so goes
the tragedy of many trilogies.
With SO many subplots, so many characters,
and so much ambition, and it being so long
it’s not hard to see why some of this got a little messy.
None of this even takes in to account that
this whole social unrest scenario is an elaborate
fabrication from the League of Shadows to
Destroy Gotham, which of course begs the question
why even bother with all this French revolution stuff?
But that's gonna have to be the subject of another video.
With a little more finessing and tad more
attention on world building, this film could
have been a Wisecrackian wet dream, and a
fitting conclusion to one of the best trilogies
of our time.
It’s almost that. But,
it's not.
Thanks for watching Wisecrac, Peace!